[Music]
this is Star Talk Neil deGrasse Tyson
here your personal astrophysicist and we
have our Cosmic queries Edition a fan
favorite Chuck you know it's a fan
favorite they love it they love it they
just love it love it inquiring minds
want to know that's what it comes down
to and we put out the expertise of our
guests and what the topic is and then we
get flooded with questions and today
we've got a colleague of mine David
Kipping from up at Columbia University
yeah the department of astronomy and
astrophysics he has tap roots from the
UK at the Cambridge University and
University College London and he's he's
part of what they call the cool worlds
lab we're going to ask him about that
okay
David welcome to Star Talk
yeah the name is is not supposed to be
like dope planets
it really is cool like actually
temperature cool plants but I appreciate
that dope ass place
you want to be one of us
you wish you could I need some get down
yeah right it's so and you're no
stranger to the uh social media
platforms you've got your own YouTube
channel that has nearly a million
subscribers dude nice Keep It Coming
yeah yeah that's uh that's all pandemic
to thank for that I think you know we
just I've been making these videos for
years and people just got into it
recently let's let's not be
um
um false falsely humble
we can look at you David we know why
it's happening
we can look right at you no no no no
we see the Superman swoop that's just
this that's just this camera okay we see
it David we we understand with the lock
of hair across the forehead right yeah
the boy band of physics there's a lot of
filters happening here to me no Chuck
the real issue here is most people just
ate Cheetos and binged on TV shows and
he creates an entire YouTube Empire in
the time right well there it is so let
me ask you David so tell us what are
dope ass what's the dope ass world's lab
it's not we don't usually go by the name
but cool world's lab is uh it's it's the
research team I started here at Columbia
so you know we're there was a team
called the cool Stars lab in uh San
Diego I think and I thought that was a
great name because obviously it's a fun
playing Words and everyone's interested
in cool stars
um and as as we've been scrubbing more
and more planets you know we know of
lots and lots of plants which are close
to their stars but it's the plants which
are far away from their star where the
temperatures are cool enough that we get
really excited because then you have the
possibility of liquid water all this
kind of stuff coal is a relative term so
what would cool beans yeah yeah quantify
this quantify this we're deliberately
vague in that sense
okay yeah there's no there's no like if
you're you know 301 Kelvin you're too
hot but 300 Kelvin you're good there's
no hard there's no hard line it kind of
depends on the science problem you know
we we're interested in moons that's one
of the big things for instance that
really doesn't directly have anything to
do with temperature but actually does
kind of work out that way that when
you're far away from the Star there's a
better chance of moon so yeah but you're
counting wait you're counting Earth as
being far away from the Sun
it's a cool world in this picture yeah
yeah cool all right so so why do we have
so many exoplanets that are so close to
their host star
that's just detection bias unfortunately
I mean I wish it wasn't true
um
tell us about that because we hear about
bias all the time and usually it's some
psychological bias no one is thinking
that there could be actual scientific
bias that has nothing to do with how
whether you're a bigot we're used to it
happening at a traffic stop yeah exactly
so tell us what you mean by a detection
bias yeah it's not bigoted astronomers
in this case you know that does
sometimes happen that's not what's
Happening Here the the real the real
problem is that the mo the most
successful way of discovering plants is
this Transit methods sure you've talked
about many times on Star Talk the idea
of as a plant eclipses in front of the
star it blocks out some of the Starlight
and of course the star gets dimmer but
in order to get that chance alignment uh
it's it's much much easier if the star
is and the planet are very very close
together right when you put them far
apart to get that chance alignment it's
kind of hard to show but it's it's kind
of probable the the longer the access is
the less likely is you're going to get
that those two objects to line up and so
for that reason so this is like looking
for your uh looking for your car keys
under the lamp post because that's where
you're going to find them so if you're
going to look for planets you're most
likely to find just those planets that
are close by and they're so close that
they're very hot for being so close to
their host star I guess that's the
problem unfortunately for me I mean some
folks are fascinated by those hot plants
I'm obviously more interested in the
cooler objects on the possibility of
Life ultimately
in in part I mean as I said a big part
of one of the reasons I love these
things is just Exotica can happen out
here you can have icy Rings you can have
exo moons there's even a paper on the
archive that will surely get debunked
tomorrow claiming of a Trojan exoplanet
of these kind of distances tell everyone
what the archive is and then tell
everyone about Trojan
Trojan objects there's a regular posting
um an electronic repository called the
archive but it's archived with an X and
um astronomers can post discoveries
papers that they have usually they've
been through peer review but sometimes
like the paper that was up today I don't
think it had been peer-reviewed yet and
there was a claim of uh two new planets
which happen to be in the same orbit as
each other
yeah they're chasing each other so
that's called a horseshoe orbit and
theoretically that's possible
um I just think a lot of us are pretty
skeptical about the data for this
particular case okay all right and so
then you set something about
EXO moons would you have rings icy rings
out here moons and liquid water life
um okay there's all sorts of fun Jazz
that can happen
that's why they're cool stars of course
yeah cool worlds sorry cool worlds all
right so Chuck you got questions for
this man I do let's do it as usual our
people have come through Forest let's
jump right into it just to be clear
these are patreon members who have are
at least the minimum membership level
right which we reduced yes we dropped it
down the five dollars to give you no
excuse spiders now you got no damn
excuses you got no excuse five dollars a
month and then you get to ask questions
okay it yeah here we go for a cool world
uh what's the largest planet that's ever
discovered and how large I like that can
a planet get conceivably how large could
a planet get let me think yeah that
makes sense because our son isn't so big
so are there Suns out there that are
like super big and then they have super
big planets around them yeah yeah okay
yeah no no quite so uh let's let's track
back so for planets usually uh the
biggest planet that was cold if it was
cool and there was no heat involved or
anything like this pretty much the
biggest plant you can get is Jupiter
sized you actually if you just spoon
more mass onto Jupiter it doesn't get
any bigger it just it just gets more
massive and its density increases but
its physical Size Doesn't Really change
if anything actually gets slightly
smaller you get the slice it slightly
okay so often in the public when people
say big they don't always know whether
they're referring to size or mass right
I think those are those are conflated
often when people are asking questions
in the public so you you make a very
interesting point you can increase the
mass of Jupiter right by spooning matter
into it and the extra gravity actually
compresses the gas right more than it
otherwise would
yeah so I mean in terms of the the
maximum Mass let's do that let's just
keep spinning Mass on eventually it'll
become a star it kind of goes through
this period of being a brown dwarf but I
think lots of us think well Brown dwarfs
that's kind of a made-up category to
some degree it's effectively still just
a type of Jupiter some kind of super
Jupiter and eventually when you start
spooning enough Mass on you'll get to
the critical point which I think we can
all agree something special happens
which is when hydrogen fusion occurs
there's enough pressure inside the in
the core of that object that hydrogen
occurs and now you have a star and that
happens in about 80 Jupiter masses
you've been spawning more and more mass
onto it so therefore the the pressures
down in the middle keep going up
correct okay so about 80 80 times the
massive Jupiter so Jupiter is not close
to being a failed star I mean people say
do you miss a failed star it has to be
80 times more eight times more mass to
get it's a it's kind of a long way off I
would say from being a failed stuff but
it has a similar size physical size to
the smallest stars that is true
interesting okay it's really great
Jupiter already has more mass than all
other planets combined right but you're
saying it could have been even more
massive and we'd still call it a planet
and then
nothing else matters in the solar system
except the star and Jupiter like nothing
you know what I tell people Chuck that
Jupiter is more bigger compared to Earth
than Earth is compared to Pluto
okay so if you're on if you're an
Earthling and you want to say let's get
rid of Pluto's planet status
and you feel good about yourself right
if we were jupitarians we could feel the
same way and kick Earth out and we'd
have no recourse right because yeah but
but also size does matter uh so
if you really want to get these plants
big you have to add heat so you take one
of these Jupiters and you you park it
next to a really hot star
it puffs up so then you can get up to
something like
170 percent the size of Jupiter so 1.7
times larger probably not quite I think
I don't think we have any ones that are
twice as big but they get pretty close
to that so so a tad under twice the size
of Jupiter is kind of our limits for
planets no matter where they are as far
as we know I mean that's the funny thing
about science you never know someone
might make a discovery to remember three
a three Jupiter sized planet and uh you
know there's even ideas of Dark Matter
planets Dark Matter planets would be
extremely large probably larger than the
sun in fact so now you're creating your
own queries
that's amazing it's a hypothetical it's
a hypothetical but dark matter doesn't
like to Clump you know it's it's very
diffuse it interacts very weakly and so
it's kind of hard to um collapse it down
to cool it down as normal gases when it
when normal gas gets hot it cools down
it radiates and so it cools down the Gas
collapses and eventually cools down to a
point where you can actually start to
form stars because the gases has
concentrated so much dark matter doesn't
really do that but there are some
varieties of Dark Matter models that
allow for a bit more clumpiness it's
allowed to kind of interact a bit more
strongly that could in extreme it's a
fairly extreme idea but in some extreme
versions it could potentially form a
dark matter Planet but it would be
larger than the sun uh it would end of
order of you know just a few Earth
masses and it'll be very weakly bound
together so it'd be a pretty um but then
what right would you have to call it a
planet
just that that's for I I really don't
care about it it's a gathering yeah over
here I don't know what to call it yeah I
mean people you talked about Pluto I
never get into that debate I'm like I'll
call it whatever you want I I it's
interesting it's an interesting world
all right okay all right uh we're gonna
take a quick break when we come back
more questions for David Kipping on what
do we call it
badass worlds oh yeah dope ass work
don't pass words
cool worlds among the exoplanets in our
galaxy when Star Talk returns
we're back Star Talk Cosmic queries the
cool worlds Edition with the founder of
the cool worlds Lab at Columbia
University David Kipping uh so David
what how many people are part of this
lab
Let's see we have I have three graduate
students right now
um and at any one time there's somewhere
between sort of three and six
undergraduates it's sort of this is a
stochastic variation in that sense all
right so this you just you just invented
this out of whole cloth
yeah yeah I also have an editor as well
for my videos because the whole there's
a whole separate thing of the videos we
make on on YouTube
and you know he he edits my videos but
isn't involved in the research directly
and what's the name of your Channel
just cool worlds that's cool world I
wasn't very creative I had this one
great idea for a name and I just kept
using it okay just you should have come
to me and Chuck we would have said dope
ass planets
we totally could have hooked you up you
know call next time or your time machine
yeah all right Chuck you got more
questions from our patreon supporters
yep let's do it from patreon this is
Richard Hart and Richard says
Richard here from Elk Grove California
looking at Hano rain's exoplanet app
there are more than 300 planets noted in
the capital zone of their stars of which
a vast majority of them are at least
half the mass of Jupiter or bigger sir
is this just a result of how we're
currently detecting planets or do you
think it's a potentially common
occurrence for a gas giant to be in the
habitable zone of its star oh I like
that that's a good question it kind of
makes sense the way he poses it yeah
yeah that's definitely something we're
excited about and it rings true I mean
you have to be careful when you look at
this these catalogs like on the Apple on
on NASA exoplanet archives another great
website if you want to go through all of
these yourself I'm not sure if Hano is
still updating that app anymore so it
might I'm sure there's even more
actually past that because the total the
total exoplanets are over five thousand
seems to me we would have more than 300
in a Goldilocks Zone you'd think yeah
possibly
um I'm not sure but in any case uh that
you have to be careful because of all
these biases you know these detection
biases that you don't you're only ever
seeing a fraction of the true true
number so people have done the
calculation of correcting for that bias
to actually figure out how many plants
are there really in this temperate zone
and it turns out that you're right that
there are a a surprisingly large number
about 50 percent of All sun-like Stars
fgk type Stars we call them sun-like
Stars they have planets with radii in
between about twice out of the Earth all
the way up to the biggest Jupiter so the
all of those are gas giants mini mini
gas giants Neptunes mini Neptunes super
Neptunes Saturns so that's even
correcting for the observer's bias
correct half okay of all stars have
gaseous planets in a hyperzone which
which obviously don't have Solid
Surfaces wait wait wait wait there's
something different from what you said I
I thought half of all
planets in the habitable zones are that
size you're saying half of All Stars
correct oh my God that's a whole lot
that's a lot that's a lot yes that's a
very color that's from Kepler statistics
uh for Earth's we were the answer is
telescope designs specifically for these
discoveries yeah correct thank you yeah
not the NASA mission that flew or was it
2009 to 2014-15 sure so we we know that
um there are lots and lots of those
gases plants which could have moons and
that's why we're so excited to look for
them and in fact there may even be far
more than earth-sized planets at that
distance we actually don't know what the
number is of how many Earths there are
at that distance yeah
so if so you like the moons because they
get you like moons of gaseous planets
because they give you a surface to hang
out on right
right I mean that that could be there
could be more habitable moons than
Capital planets in the universe other
aliens could be looking at us thinking
what's going on over there why are they
living on a planet like most of us live
on moves yeah that's why they're not
interested in us we're like we're just
these weird people living on a planet
I'm gonna say that's the one cool thing
that I like about Star Wars when it
comes to how they Envision other worlds
and galaxies Solar Systems is that often
you're they're going to a moon of a
planet they're not going to that planet
it's whatever system but then where
they're actually Landing is a moon
itself you know yeah I would I would
also add that the host planet is going
to look way better in the sky right from
a moon than the moon is from the planet
just imagine Saturn in the night sky
just looming large wow just that would
just be totally cool that is cool yeah I
always wonder how history would be
different
um had we had happened to us like how
would we discover the laws of physics
differently Celestial mechanics uh the
Kepler's laws of motions would the
presence of such a large body in our Sky
accelerate it will it decelerate it
um obviously there's all this kind of
radio stuff flying off a Jupiter as well
would that affect the technology we
develop on our home planet our home
world even so uh it's it's it's right
for science fiction that's why Star Wars
has so much fun with that so I think
about it the opposite way David if we
evolved on the surface of Venus which is
a very thick cloud cover and it would
just get sort of get light in the day
and dark at night but you wouldn't know
how long how much delayed would
astronomy have been
yeah because you'd have no idea what's
going on outside of this fog and we
would all have seasonal affective
disorders so you know it'd be like look
up why
it's so sad yes
all right Chuck keep him coming all
right let's go to Matthew power and what
a great name Matthew power uh since some
planets in our solar system have higher
concentrations of certain elements iron
on Mars for example does that suggest
our original solar nebula once flattened
by a central centrifugal force may have
been ring-like with bands of certain
elements that eventually formed the
planets sort of a solar system-sized
version of Saturn's rings oh I like that
wow because that would mean that
different places within the ring would
coalesce to form a planet and have a
very different concentration from other
places in the disk so how does that all
land with you David
yeah that's really interesting question
in terms of iron abundance
um
I'm not I'm actually I've not heard that
before that Mars has a higher higher
abundance than the earth Mercury wins
Mercury Mercury definitely does I know
of course right but Mercury is somewhat
of a strange case usually the
explanation we evoke from making sense
what's going with Mercury is I mean
generally we kind of assume that all the
planets formed with roughly the same
amount of iron at least in a relative
sense compared to their Mass but Mercury
does seem to have a lot more iron than
the other planets in a relative sense
and so our explanation for that is that
it was basically struck by many many
meteorites with such high velocity such
high energy they actually chipped away
the the outer layer of mercury so you're
saying it chips away pieces of mercury
they're then just goes jettisoned into
the solar system or even just vaporize
to some degree from the impact and then
and then leaked off as as Vapor that's
also possible so it's like Cosmic
exfoliation very good yeah it's like a
chemical peel yeah
almost for the planet so that probably
explained we think why mercury has
higher iron abundance but generally
we're seeing that for the rest of the
planets it is uniform and in fact that
is often treated as a default assumption
when we look at other exoplanets we
assume that there's you don't know if
I'm sure about Mars though we're not
quite sure you're not quite sure I I'm
not sure I'm not sure I've never heard
that before so I'd have to fact check
that that Mars I always like to be
honest when I don't well I've not heard
something before I've never heard the
fact that Mars has a higher iron
abundance than the earth I'd be somewhat
surprised if it's true because I just
from my expertise of looking at
exoplanks I know that many of my
colleagues explicitly assume that iron
abundance is uniform throughout any
given solar system with exceptions like
Mercury we can't deny Mars the fact that
it's red because of iron iron in its
outer crust I mean everywhere that's
pretty much just a rusty place right but
I yeah I think I think that's partly due
to the the unique history of that plant
and it's it's distinct chemical
environment and the oxidation that
happen on its surface that is different
from Earth and Venus
you implied something that I want to
tease out here because it's it's a very
important scientific tool really that
you can make an assumption about
you can make a reasonable assumption
about how much iron you'd expect in all
the planets based on the iron that's in
the sun because the iron the sun has
most of the mass of the solar system
then when the if the iron differs from
that
you get to then look for an explanation
for that
which is a fascinating way to land on a
new problem we did that with the Moon
the Moon has hardly any iron
so how do you get become an object that
big with no iron
did so then we looked and we thought
about and then we came with the
Collision hypothesis for yeah for the
moon so it's fun when something falls
out of your expectations you it you get
novel accountings for the that's
actually why I don't like this uh this
strategy that many of my colleagues have
of assuming explicitly that the iron
abundance in the star is the same as the
past because as you just point out
there's already two counter examples
right there and there's there's probably
even more that's right no no I get that
but if it is different then you get to
look for why it's different rather we in
exopaths we have no way of directly
measuring the iron but it's at least not
yet I mean okay I think the only way to
do that would be if the if the planet
was so hot it was like Mustafa from Star
Wars it was like a lava world where The
Rock was literally gaseous and then you
could then you could infer the
composition of of the Rock from the
atmosphere but barring that we have no
way of measuring the chemical
composition of what's inside how about i
i o around Jupiter on aren't there
active volcanoes there could you get
some yeah that's a good example so yeah
yeah kind of like a mustafa-ish type
system right where you have extreme
volcanism where you can spew up the
gases and then you get a chance of
sampling what was inside you need that
yeah all right that's that's pretty wild
all right Chuck give me another all
right blowing through these all right
this is Christian Holmes who says gritty
doctor Tyson and Professor Kipping quick
question what is the most extreme
exoplanet that's been observed thank you
Christian from Pennsylvania now
Christian does not qualify the word
extreme yeah so I don't know exactly
what he means but maybe David you you
can take Liberty with it okay let me
sharpen that question and say David you
presumably have catalogs of exoplanets
now there's more than five thousand so
presumably they they line up with each
other in ways that reveal similarities
is there an outlier
among the five thousand that you that
where nobody else looks like it
I think this it's hard to pick on one
that there's there's several plants
which which come to mind in this case
um
one is one I helped kind of discover its
weirdness of immediately comes to mind
because it got so much press attention
when we released it was like 10 years
ago now and it was called trays to be
and we called it a Rebus the darkest
world the Rebus was the god of Darkness
I think in Greek mythology uh maybe it
was Roman mythology but we we caught it
you didn't say it right Chuck it has to
say it no go ahead
[Laughter]
yeah I like it yeah you should you
should do all the all the Press work for
that
um yeah so this this planet is darker
than coal it's darker than black paint
it reflects less light than basically
any material you can come across
Advanced black except for vanderberg
except for Banta black but we don't know
it might be as dark as Fanta back we
only have an upper limit on its Darkness
as far as we can tell what is Santa
black it's uh least reflective material
that we know of to date so it is it has
uh an Albedo of
wait so David if it doesn't reflect any
light how do you know it's there
from transits it's still casts a shadow
it's still casts a shadow so as it
passes in front of the Stars don't pass
world
that's what I'll talk about all right
that's a shout out but it's very dark so
when it when it passes around when it
passes in front of the star it blocks
out light when it passes behind the star
we call that the awkwardation event you
get kind of a moment where you get to
detect photons from the planet light
from the planet so I can take a picture
just here just before the planet passes
behind and now I'm getting light from
the planet and light from the Star and I
take a photo of the two and then I take
a photo when it's behind and now I've
just got light from the Star by itself
so subtract one from the other and
you've got light from the planet in
isolation and that's what we call it a
quotation so that's how that's how we're
able to tell you God I gotta love
science I know yeah I love it fix it is
crap
yeah
oh by the way just a a small fact in
there that it's very dangerous
to subtract
and explore the difference between two
large numbers
So you you're very yeah so David your
confidence in that in those results uh
you have to you have to be very sure
that you're getting what you're looking
for there correct that's right but it's
not my first radio you know say okay
yeah
[Laughter]
he published a subsequent work that
ended up the same result so we feel
pretty confident so Chuck you notice
it's not him reconfirming his own
results because what good would that be
right the whole point of peer review and
and multiple studies that's how science
moves science loves the haters baby yes
we do
like go ahead and Hate on me no they're
not really haters did they're doing it
out of love
of course they are
they will try to show you're wrong
because they love you there you go oh
they love science I love science yeah
well the truth is in a way it is kind of
loving because in in trying to show
somebody's wrong you end up confirming
their work and that ends up showing them
love so yeah yeah wow cool all right all
right one more Chuck before we take our
second break okay here we go uh long ago
I was impressed by a professional oh
this is Gene and Gene is just Gene okay
uh he goes long ago I was impressed by a
professional astronomer who was studying
clips and binary Stars I was and am
amazed by how much info one can extract
with careful measurements and clever
bootstrapping now we are using the same
techniques on exoplanets and the James
Webb Space Telescope add spectral
measurements of atmospheres could you
give a brief summary of what and how we
can get details from eclipsing systems
so
yo we're talking about all of it not
just one exoplanet going in front of the
star but the whole system the whole star
says all right that's that's whatever
however long it's going to take him to
answer we don't have time in this
segment so let's take a break when we
come back we'll get the full explanation
of how the message tools and tactics of
eclipsing binary stars have been lifted
and adopted and modified in the service
of David kipping's dope ass
um
but when Star Talk Cosmic queries
continues
we're back start off Cosmic queries cool
worlds Edition with David Kipping who
started his own cool worlds group at
Columbia's Department of astronomy and
astrophysics Columbia University that is
uh David you've got your your your
successful and growing
uh uh YouTube called cool world uh what
else tell me more about your social
media footprint Rhythm was starting and
it's not it's not live yet is the cool
words podcast which I've recorded I
think seven episodes of we have seven
episodes in the in the tank and I'm just
really excited to start sharing those so
as soon as we get to that you can look
on all the major platforms you get your
podcast for the cool worlds excellent
excellent and you're on Twitter
yes David underscore Kipping is me under
that so we left off tell me the Chap's
name Chuck Gene Gene that could be a boy
or girl yeah because we do not know the
gender so Jean wanted to know what
message tools and tactics were borrowed
from eclipsing binaries that to serve
your cottage industry of of cold worlds
yeah an enormous amount I mean this in
fact so many astronomers moved from that
field of eclipsing binaries into the
study of planets directly that was the
transition around the mid 90s when we
first started finding planets there's a
really beautiful quote
um from Henry Norris Russell from 1953 I
think he wrote this that eclipses are
the royal road to success and that
they're kind of a shortcut they provide
you it's almost like a cheat code in the
universe for some for some reason when
these eclipses happen it's possible to
learn so much more about these planets
than your technology would seem to
enable like we can measure potentially
existence of of moons as we've already
talked about you can measure the
atmosphere of the planets you could look
for Rings you could even measure the
ablateness whether it's spherical or
football shaped on a planet from those
light curves you can measure the surface
reflectivities we've talked about these
dark planets there's an almost endless
list of of wonderful gems the eclipses
also enable you to see light from the
Star move through the atmosphere
and then do spectroscopic studies
correct and that's what of course we're
all excited about what jdbst it's uh
enabling
um so essentially when the plant pass in
front the same thing it's passing for
the star some of the light will will hit
the bulk of the planet if you like you
hit the solid surface and that's never
going to reach us that's the shadow but
some of it will pass through the
atmosphere and if it passes through the
atmosphere only a fraction of it will
reach us and the fraction which reaches
us will be different at different
wavelengths different colors so our sky
is blue and so the Earth's atmosphere
looks bigger in Blue Light it scatters
blue more than it scatters red so an
alien looking at the Earth and measuring
our size would think that the Earth was
a little bit bigger that blue
wavelengths of light than it was in red
wavelengths light because of rally
scattering because our sky is blue and
they'd even be able to tell that from
afar and get a bit further you can get
the chemicals and get oxygen you can get
carbon dioxide nitrogen so you can
actually figure out a lot about it all
from eclipses Henry Norris Russell was
at one point the chair of the Department
of astrophysics at Princeton University
that's right Norris Russell and uh those
the real Geeks out there might have
heard of the hurtsprung Russell diagram
that's the same Russell uh yeah for that
diagram you can Google it hurts sprung
Russell yeah diagram yeah HR diagram for
short the affectionate term for it so
Gene was right to realize that this
Trove of information brought to us from
eclipsing binaries
continues in the field of exoplanets
whenever you have eclipses there's a
legacy but it goes even beyond that I
mean when you look at the theory that we
we borrowed from eclipse and binaries
and I studied this like co-pal was one
of the founders of understanding
elliptical orbits and modeling the
durations of the eclipses the timing
procession the secular all this kind of
complicated session mechanics was all
figured out for eclipse and binaries so
we took that and we still use it in
exoplanets but then we've gone further
because of course we're measuring
atmospheres we'll implantry atmospheres
and stars they have atmospheres but
they're not nearly as interesting as the
atmospheres of plants and all the rich
chemical molecular chemistry that can
happen inside them so uh Stars would
agree with you on that I think they have
that they're just
dishes maybe I may be biased but
infinitely infinitely uh more complex
than stuff we actually understand Stars
far better than we understand plants you
know there's we don't really understand
what's going on inside most parts so how
their atmospheres work how clouds work
even on other plants but you know we
feel like we have a fairly good
understanding of the interior of stars
right because clouds can be made of
things other than water vapor right
right yeah you can have methane clouds
right yeah by the way I I produced daily
just in case anybody's wondering okay no
smoking around Chuck
I am a fire hazard
all right keep coming chuck all right
here we go
um here we go this is Kyla Hunter and
Kyla says hello Dr Tyson and Professor
Kipping could the asteroid and Kuiper
belts be considered rings of the Sun
hmm so you got the asteroid belt yeah
well Saturn has rings and it's flat and
it's all around and so we got these two
belts here what are you thinking David
yeah I mean Rocky Rings sure you could
call them that I mean it is possible
that plants could have rocky rings so if
you're going to call Rocky rings around
planet's rings I don't see why you
couldn't call Rocky ring structures
around Stars the same thing sure uh you
know it it's the question is how
concentrated does it get because
normally they form almost like discs
rather than or an annuli they're they're
not often uh so narrow so it I guess it
depends on your on your structure there
is actually an exopath that was
discovered that has
a a ring system that forces us to tackle
this weird thing of definition it was um
it was discovered by the Wasps of it I
think it was like
j1407b was the name and it has a ring
system that is wasp is is it's a planet
survey right so the correct it's just
small cameras it's just small yeah it's
a Consortium of small cameras and what
is the acronym it's um wide area search
for planets something like that that
sounds right yeah I'm not even sure we
all call it wasp yeah I was gonna say
maybe they're just white cameras watch
cameras you know yeah that's from these
ackermans we'll forget where they come
from eventually yeah this this
particular planet discovered by wasp uh
has this gigantic ring system uh that
that is about the same it's about One AU
across that's about the Earth's orbit
around the sun it's like that's how
large the ring structure around this
exoplanet is an expat it's very very far
from its star and it has a gargantuan
sized ring system and this huge cavity
is in it and you know I've seen artists
illustrations of this now that you're
mentioning it it's a stunning thing how
does it it's a stable ring while it's
orbiting the star
it's it's very we don't even know if it
is orbiting the star there's only one
eclipse of this thing ever seen which is
where the evidence for the Rings come
from it may not it may have just been a
chance coincidence that it passed in
front of a star and it was free-floating
as far as we know okay it could be brown
dwarf it could even be a small star
perhaps so there's a there's an awful
lot we don't know about this particular
case we just have this one snapshot but
this Rich uh apparent like ring sister
and that's a good point where we don't
know it's so different to Saturn what do
you call that is it a planetary ring
system or is it a circum planetary disc
which is a high a completely different
category normally of of how we think
about these things that evolve around
planets so what Jupiter when it Formed
its moons probably at one point had a
disc around it and from that disc formed
the moons is this something like that or
is it more like something like an
ancient ring system more similar to
Saturn and so uh it's hard
classification is hard and I if you want
to classify the the you know Droid belt
that way I I wouldn't dismiss it yeah I
think that's a fair way to call it okay
cool cool okay all right chuck if we got
time for a few more okay let's go with
Alan rayer uh what are the major
interesting astronomical events that we
can expect with respect to exoplanets
for the coming year I love that yeah and
then he says uh hi I'm from Lithuania
Chuck you probably already killed my
last name but
and you're probably right but you didn't
give me a phonetic spelling so
give it give us that last name again
you're Alan rayer or ryer
r-a-y-e-r yeah rare rare one of the
other but but what's what's coming down
the pike
tipping what what what can we look
forward to this might be exciting more
space there's a bunch of stuff just you
guys on Earth
that I I'm excited let's see what I'm
expect there's obviously jwc's in the
sky observing extra planets right now
and it's observing trappist-1 which is
one of the most fascinating exopatra
systems we've ever discovered it it
probably won't be sensitive enough to
detect Signs of Life on those plants but
it could perhaps tell us whether these
planets have an atmosphere that is
similar and these are rocky planets in
the Habra zone of Their Stars it could
tell us whether these planets have
um an atmosphere similar to a primordial
Earth when the Earth was first born it
was probably a CO2 Rich atmosphere it
could detect that quite easily it could
have set to methane Rich atmosphere it
probably can't go all the way to
detecting oxygen on these planets but
it's going to be our first glimpse of
the chemical composition of a habitable
Rocky planet's atmosphere and that
that's going to come in the next year
two years from JD West wait how many
isn't that a multi-planet system how
many planets there's seven at least
seven crazy size if that's slightly so
birth size in that system the Seven
Dwarfs they're all packed very very
close to this m dwarf all within the
orbit of mercury I think or seven of
them so very very compact system
um so that's very exciting then we have
uh Plato which is a European Mission
which is coming down the pipe I think
Plato yeah after the after the
philosopher so that's in 2026 I think
we're expecting a launch that's like a a
super Kepler or even a super test these
are two missions which NASA launched to
hunt for a plants by eclipses Plato's
doing the same thing on steroids and
then down the road we have from that we
have uh W first which is this old spy
satellite which was given to NASA and
it's basically a Hubble sized mirror
that the the NSA would just like we
don't we don't need this anymore because
it's such a whole technology you can
have it and do something with it so
we've repurposed it and launching it as
a basically a Hubble class telescope
that'll do all sorts of stuff including
some exoplanet science uh using a
technique called gravitational micro
lensing so it should find thousands of
objects using this technique so we're
very excited about that and then of
course you've got Vera Reuben formerly
known as lsst which is not really an
exoplanet Mission per se but I think it
could do some interesting things in
terms of detecting planets around white
dwarf stars so the sun will eventually
become a white dwarf star when it dies
and lsst we wrote a paper about that in
my team we think could be the perfect
telescope to detect thousands of rocky
planets even smaller than that even
asteroid sized things around these white
dwarfs well you know what that brings us
to Captain James Reilly who uh just as a
perfect follow-up to everything you just
said if we found bio signatures on an
exoplanet what would be our next course
of action considered like they're so far
away
so what do you do you're the dog that
caught the
cars and I would have the immediate I
had would be skepticism because I think
we're all going to be deepest so the
perfect is it real because we had a
biased energy detection already on Venus
right remember that there was phosphine
I remember yeah yeah and uh you know
that that's the reaction that played out
after that is probably similar to the
reaction that will play out for an
exoplan obviously it's a very we can
actually visit Venus we could actually
potentially go there and do a better job
but the skepticism that that happened I
think will be similar to the skepticism
that happens with an EXO pack well just
in all fairness to the Venus
skepticism the that would have been life
somehow thriving in Venus's atmosphere
whereas these other signatures would
presumably indicate surface life
right I mean we won't even know I mean
if we detected by signature we don't
know where that life is it could be in
the ocean and the gas has come up it
could be on the surface it could be some
kind of whale that that floats through
the clouds you know there's just there's
no way of telling from the gases Alone
um an air whale yeah yeah why not knock
yourself out you can have any kind of
Life floating between the fighting and
in fact it might not so the two
questions is it really is the signal
real can another team get it which has
obviously been some problems with Venus
with phosphine and then two even if it
is real does that actually mean it's
life because there are ways that nature
can produce bio signatures without
biology and just and just trip you up so
there'll be enough there'll be a decade
of arguing and follow-up observations
and debates and it'll get heated of
people trying to figure out what's
really going on and there'll be some
false starts I guarantee you there'll be
several buyer signature claims that will
just not be real but that's okay that's
how science work science Works through
we're not dogmatic it's corrective we're
allowed to make mistakes and fix it and
that's that's science at its healthiest
so just expect that down the road but
eventually uh yeah it would be great if
we could one day start Imaging these
planets maybe building something like
luvoir or habex that people have been
talking about these kind of super-sized
telescopes that could image the pale
blue dots from many light years away you
know achieve Sagan's dream of a pale
blue duck from from across an entirely
different star system and then after
that uh we'll be trying to learn more
and more about it does it have moons you
know what's what's the Continental
structure like how much water does it
have we'll do as much as we can remotely
and perhaps in the distant future we
might be able to send something but it's
it's certainly not something within our
capabilities uh in the near future all
right Chuck I don't know if we have time
for any more I think we're done here a
lot a lot more uh questions might have
to come and do a part two yeah yeah
you say yeah guys you have fulfilled our
expectation that these are dope ass
worlds yes yes
we'll have to rename the you know have
to rename the whole team I think after
this world dope ass world all right
David great to know you're just up the
street from us at Columbia University
it's my alma mater my PhD alma mater the
very fond memories and affection for the
place and the department so say hi to
everybody there who knows me they also
we saw you just two days ago
[Laughter]
see you here after yeah yeah
always a pleasure all right Neil
deGrasse Tyson here your personal
keep looking up
foreign
[Music]